con una superficie de 284 mil kilómetros
cuadrados y algo más de 16 millones de
habitantes ecuador es el país más
densamente poblado de toda sudamérica
enclavado entre colombia perú y el
océano pacífico es uno de los pocos
países del mundo que carecen de moneda
propia utilizando desde el año 2000 el
dólar de los estados unidos en los
últimos años bajo el gobierno de rafael
correa ecuador se ha convertido en un
modelo a seguir para muchos políticos
analistas e intelectuales sin embargo
hoy por hoy las cosas no marcha tan bien
hoy en visual político hablamos de
caguas
la economía ecuatoriana se encuentra
atravesando un difícil momento de
acuerdo con las últimas previsiones del
fmi y el banco mundial y otros
organismos internacionales el pd de
ecuador se está desplomando pero como se
ha llegado a esa situación y cuáles son
las auténticas dimensiones de esta
crisis para responder estas preguntas
tenemos que remontarnos a inicios del
2007 cuando asumí el gobierno rafael
correa y puso en marcha la conocida como
revolución ciudadana un programa
político de corte chavista bolivariano
que empezó por todo lo grande en 2008 y
tras una auditoría realizada por la
llamada comisión para la auditoría
integral del crédito público ecuador
anunció el impago de la deuda
considerada como ilegítima hay
compromisos nacionales urgentes y
nosotros primero pondremos los
compromisos nacionales a los compromisos
internacionales personalmente estamos a
las auditorías de la deuda me tiene
fascinado qué culpa tienen los
pensionistas alemanes por ejemplo de que
el dinero que prestaron fueran al
utilizado por quien lo pidió bueno
rafael correa aprovechó un momento de
fortaleza económica del país un momento
en el que la deuda pública era
relativamente pequeña unos diez mil
millones de euros es decir menos del 1
por qué
de la deuda pública que tiene hoy españa
para anunciar que suspendía los pagos de
aproximadamente un tercio de la deuda
exterior dejó dicho que ahorita no puede
pagar pero que mañana seguro seguro
seguro seguro que tampoco el resultado
fue que ante el miedo a no cobrar los
inversores empezaron a deshacerse de los
títulos afectados vendiendo los con
fuertes descuentos en el mercado y que
ocurrió pues que fue el propio gobierno
quien los compró pagando 35 dólares por
cada título que le obligaba a pagar 100
dólares más intereses tal cual toda una
artimaña casi un chantaje que teniendo
como ingrediente principal el miedo le
permitió a ecuador ahorrarse pagos por
cerca de 7 mil millones de dólares eso
sí a costa de retratarse como un país
poco fiable en el que invertir
aún artificios urgentes y por otra parte
el vertiginoso aumento de los precios
del petróleo en la última década supuso
que el gobierno de correa tuviese acceso
a una gigantesca cantidad de recursos
económicos y quite con ellos pues
disparar el gasto público durante los
años del presidente correa el gasto
público ha crecido a un ritmo cinco
veces más rápido que la propia economía
ecuatoriana el resultado es que el
tamaño del estado se ha doblado
la llamada 'revolución ciudadana' y hoy
representa ya casi la mitad de toda la
economía nacional claro semejante
inyección de recursos hizo que la
economía creciese y ecuador-
experimentarse lo que casi podemos
considerar como una época dorada
la clase media aumentó se pusieron en
marcha todo tipo de programas sociales
la pobreza se redujo en más de un millón
y medio de personas y la inversión
pública en infraestructuras alcanzó
récords históricos además la educación
ha sido una de las niñas mimadas y hoy
ecuador destina en ella un 5,3 por
ciento del pib con lo que ojo es el país
latinoamericano que proporcionalmente
más dinero gasta en este concepto
tampoco nos podemos olvidar de las
políticas proteccionistas otra de las
apuestas claras del govern ecuatoriano
es inadecuado un mecanismo de control y
gobernanza esta globalización puede
devastar países en definitiva
rafael correa en su revolución ciudadana
cobraron pronto mucha popularidad a la
izquierda tanto dentro como fuera de
ecuador e incluso periodistas españoles
tan conocidos como jordi évole se
dirigieron al presente correa en busca
de respuestas y recetas contra la crisis
casi nada pero ojo amigos no todo ha
sido tan bonito a pesar de la narración
de éxito veamos cuáles han sido las
principales claves de lo que casi
podemos denominar como crónica de una
crisis anunciada
bajo crecimiento económico
entre 2007 y 2015 el crecimiento medio
anual fue del 39 por ciento una tasa
inferior a la de perú paraguay bolivia
uruguay y colombia otros países como
argentina o chile están casi a la par
así que podemos decir que ecuador solo
ha destacado respecto a la caótica
economía de brasil de la desastrosa
economía de venezuela si además tenemos
en cuenta la mala evolución actual
observamos que la economía ecuatoriana
ha presentado una muy pobre evolución
durante el periodo de rafael correa
alto crecimiento de la deuda
a pesar de los beneficios que tuvo el
gobierno de ecuador con el impago de la
deuda y los más de 80 mil millones de
dólares obtenidos del petróleo durante
este periodo la deuda pública se ha
disparado
de hecho si sumamos todas las
obligaciones incluyendo los pagos en
petróleo a china que por cierto se ha
convertido en el mayor acreedor del país
la deuda total del estado se aproxima ya
al 90 por ciento del producto interno
bruto cuando correa llegó al poder la
deuda pública se situaba por debajo del
25 por ciento
gran dependencia en el petróleo lejos de
diversificarse la economía costera sigue
siendo hoy muy dependiente del petróleo
de tal forma que cuando el precio del
crudo se ha desplomado también lo ha
hecho la economía nacional al tiempo
claro que el déficit público se ha
escapado de todo control la situación es
tan delicada que para conseguir liquidez
el gobierno ecuatoriano ha llegado a
entregarle a goldman sachs la mitad de
las reservas de oro del país como
garantía de un préstamo ecuador
transfiere a goldman sachs más de la
mitad de sus reservas de oro en busca de
liquidez además la prima de riesgo es
tan elevada que ecuador está emitiendo
bonos a cinco años al 10 kos 35 por
ciento más que grecia el resultado es
que a pesar de lo que siempre ha dicho
correa ecuador ha pedido ayuda al
mismísimo fm fondo monetario en parte
del bid bueno los que impusieron el
neoliberalismo en américa latina y en el
mundo entero
baja inversión extranjera como
consecuencia de todas las trabas
existentes el excesivo intervencionismo
y el miedo de los inversores el ecuador
es uno de los países de américa latina
con menor inversión extranjera directa
para hacernos una idea la inversión
extranjera directa en relación al pib es
tres veces inferior a la de perú y seis
veces inferior a la que registra chile
la pobreza aún persiste
si bien la pobreza se ha reducido
sustancialmente no lo ha hecho a ritmos
mayores que los gobiernos precedentes y
además como es lógico la pobreza está
ligada a la evolución económica de tal
forma que en 2016 el ratio de pobreza
está repuntando respecto al año anterior
por todo ello podemos afirmar que más
que un milagro económico ecuador uno de
los países con menos libertad económica
de la región ha registrado durante la
etapa de rafael correa- una gran burbuja
de gasto público y como todas las
burbujas tarde o temprano explota
por fortuna para todos ecuatorianos y a
pesar de que ya hay sospechas de
manipulación por parte del gobierno de
los datos económicos dudas por el
retraso del banco central en publicar
informe de cuentas nacionales es poco
probable que la crisis alcance cotas tan
dramáticas como venezuela un gracias a
que la economía está dolarizada y para
disgusto del presidente el gobierno no
puede recurrir a la impresión de dinero
para financiarse por si fuese poco
rafael correa confesó admirador de hugo
chávez ha transformado ecuador en uno de
los países de américa latina junto a
cuba y venezuela- más restrictivos con
la libertad de expresión de la prensa y
bastante mediocre y con fuerte intereses
privados en fin que como podemos ver
este supuesto salvar del pueblo tan
venerado por la izquierda tampoco
resultó ser como nos contaron ahora te
pregunta a ti con esta opinión que es
ecuador correa más fuerte similar a la
de venezuela que se correa ha sido
beneficioso o perjudicial si te gusta es
el vídeo ver like y si te gusta la
política en la economía
suscríbete avisa al político si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta el
próximo vídeo